رحبوا بضيفنا من رام الله الدكتور محمد
المصري رئيس المركز الفلسطيني للبحوث
الفلسطينيه للدراسات الاستراتيجيه دكتور
محمد مرحبا بك معنا في ميزان الربح
والخساره وفي ما جرى خلال هذا اليوم ما
الذي تحقق لكل طرف
تحياتي لك ست سلمى والرحمه للشهدائنا وانا
انصت للتقرير التي قدم في التلفزيون الان
شعرت بانه هناك شخص محايد يتحدث عن واقع
ما حصل ويقول بانه الاحتلال فشل في هذه
المعركه وان الفلسطيني حققت انجازات كبيره
من هذه الانجازات بانه افشل كل مخططات
دوله الاحتلال اولا لم يتم الاستفراد
بالجهاد الاسلامي ثانيا بانه اغتيال
الشهداء لم يوقف الصواريخ واذا كان
اغتيالهم سيحقق لهم وقف الصواريخ فمن اين
اتت هذه الصواريخ الا اذا اكدت من قبورهم
او من الجنه انا اعتقد بان هذا الاحتلال
الفاشل جدا بالرغم انه يمتلك اسلحه ذكيه
واقول غبيه جدا لانه في حينما فتح المعركه
وباغتيال الشهداء مع عائلات النساء
واطفالهم ارتكب جريمه كبيره جدا وكان علي
ان يدفع الثمن والثمن الاول كان بالصمت
والالتزام من قبل ق
حينما قال دمرنا البنيه التحتيه لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي
الذي اريد يعني ان اسالك عنه بعض المحللين
راوا بان كان هناك فشل استراتيجي كبير
نتنياهو في هذه الجوله وربما كان هناك بعض
الانجازات التكتيكيه داخليا او على مستوى
ايضا اغتيال الشخصيات الثلاثه من الشهداء
شهداء المقاومه هل تتفق مع مثل هذه الرؤيه
[موسيقى]
قدرات لدى الجهاد الاسلامي دوله نوويه
مسلحه بكل انواع الاسلحه تواجه فصيل
فلسطيني واحد وان كان بغطاء غرفه العمليات
المشتركه وشراكه فلسطينيه معنويه وسياسيه
وتغطيه لن يسبح احدا فلسطينيا الاستفراد
من قبل الاحتلال بفصيل فلسطيني كفصيل
الجهاد الاسلامي شكرا جزيلا لك من رام
الله الدكتور محمد المصري رئيس المركز
الفلسطيني للبحوث الفلسطينيه للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه شكرا مشاركه معنا